[Music]
in fight fail Muse that's me yes I'm
gonna buy going number four what does
that mean like extremely our ears
I guess vomiting yeah Showtime is being
sued over the Mayweather MacGregor fight
after live stream glitches oh yeah yeah
oh there haven't you yeah just kind of
slow at born in James house remember we
had you but the actual fight they didn't
have a glitch thank God
well that's because I use mine I use the
live streaming on my laptop from
Showtime right yeah from Showtime
depending on how you look at the fight
it seemed pretty glitch to me it was not
fun yeah would you guys think of it well
it's boring really was it slow I mean I
really I don't want to take away from
your like break her down like she broke
you down earlier hahaha I was a lot of
fights I guess I because was McGregor I
just I'm not used to watching boxing and
I didn't know it was that like always so
you're used to watching UFC yeah that's
the only type of fights I've ever more
gentlemanly so I didn't know it was I
didn't know it was gonna be like a lot
of Mayweather going like this punches
like I watched Rocky
oh well that's why it wasn't what you
watch fiction that's why what you just
witnessed was actually more aggression
than Mayweather has ever exactly I've
been one of the most exciting bottom
that was considered excited but what's
crazy is that I remember when I was a
kid watching like all these guys box and
that was awesome yeah awesome
but this mayweather technical [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] yeah it's too smart Oh Hilary
Swank was more fun to watch than oh my
god 1 Million Dollar Baby I think as the
you know the Tyson days the Holyfield I
mean is that what you're getting bit off
because Pisces never threw a jab you've
got it we start throwing heavyweight
slugger stuff yeah that's the [ __ ] the
real [ __ ] but that fight was
exciting for me man just watching
Mayweather first of all that first three
four rounds watching him slip all those
punches was crazy all of his counter
punches he was countering his counter
punches he had that one solid uppercut
in the beginning to freak me the [ __ ]
out he came over the back it was so
interesting to COS like he was so
unorthodox like especially because like
the way I thought McGregor was gonna
fight I thought he was gonna throw big
haymakers but he was very selective as
punches and so when you usually see
boxing and especially at their weight
class boxers will come in if they see
hope they'll start swinging they'll go
bah bah bah bah but maybe whether he was
selective and he would throw Flicker
jabs quick Oh is is that's all he does
man I've never seen him threw a haymaker
yeah he couldn't it's cuz he was so
tired I think it was also really short I
thought you know I don't know I thought
it would be a round there's a lot of
rounds you want it to be like the bombs
they come in boom this is why you know
he watches rocky montages I know they've
been eating a lot of rides and I wanted
to see it'd be worth some real [ __ ] a
few payoff action movie exactly do you
see some explosions
Nagi's like it needed more uplifting
music I thought the 90 kept giving him
his back I know I am backing are you
because he was trying to get him on a
technicality
yeah wait and he was trying to get him
tired dude that was the whole point that
was his whole strategy which is why he's
so [ __ ] boring to watch
do you guys fighting everyone kept
saying he's switched it up but I wasn't
well the difference is I think McGregor
really pushed them to his limits a
little bit and it looked like Mayweather
was getting agitated and getting
aggressive and you usually never see
Mayweather being the aggressor but he
did stick to his similar tactic that
he's done before where he tires out the
opponent and toward the end of the
rounds that's when he comes in for the
kill which he did but he came in with
hard way harder than he usually does you
you just saw a different side to him you
know it was more action-packed I think
what did you guys think that the rough
came in too soon I did I'm used to UFC
fights exactly so of course he came in
too early and especially all the UFC
[ __ ] it was like I wish you would
have let me go down I was just a wobbly
you know like I did that's he just kept
on saying you know but you know
different different rules yeah he's in
and you know to that point he was
getting knocked in the face like
repeatedly he wasn't defending himself
so I'm boxing is a little different like
a UFC you got to be concussed doomed to
me like is if you're still on your feet
that's pretty good yeah I'd be proud of
myself if I could hang in there with me
weather and get punched in the face and
still stand yeah right you know to that
point though like I still do think it
was cut a little early because you know
just watching boxing as a kid when
before they even get knocked out to the
floor is a TKO big when they get hit
let's say they're going at it right and
the guy throws like a straight right up
and they're just getting at him right
and there are the ropes there like this
though Mayweather was he was bright eyed
you know I'm sorry McGregor was bright
eyed so like I did still thought it was
cut too early because even though he got
him with a straight right really hard
the other ones grazed him it was like
Batman it wasn't hitting him hard so to
me it was stopped a little earlier I
think he could have got another route
but he would have got destroyed yeah for
sure the next round
kind of rigged me like we know
Mayweather was not gonna lose yeah he's
gonna he's gonna go 49 my news also the
casinos in Vegas they're talking about
like they would lose so much money if
you're Greg Erwitt there's no [ __ ]
way that's gonna happen
and what wouldn't McGregor get what was
this fight purse like ten million or
something it was it was a 30 mil for
McGregor and a hundred mil for Oh more
than that three no no three hundred
three hundred for me no no no that was
after everything else it was a hundred
mil first 30 mil before they even
thought oh I see that's the fight purse
and then pay-per-view everything else he
got 300 mil Conor got a hundred mil yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] I got a hundred mil for
that yeah that's why he's happy no
matter what exactly well I think it's a
win-win situation for both you know um
Mayweather gets his 50 you know and he
he goes down in boxing history
McGregor you know it doesn't even hurt
his MMA career for fighting of this this
you know spherical thing that he sets
him up like well you know he wasn't
about yeah that's like if he got into
wrestling or judo or something totally
different it's like well he's just doing
something different he could come back
you know does he get another swiftly
into pop instead of country just like a
lot of like people who watch UFC and
they've never seen boxing it's a little
frustrating because like boxing has a
lot of technicality and rules right so
number one you can't hold right so
that's why you see them when they're up
do you see them kind of doing this like
what the [ __ ] is that
like because you can't grab yeah you
know so but you can't put your hand
around them to get away with it as long
as possible that's resting its resting
and it's also a tactic so you could hold
and sock the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of them
without grabbing them so that if they're
close like this right and you see them
have the arm here they're gonna [ __ ]
you know get you yeah I was I was in a
room with a bunch of dudes and of course
like when that has started happening all
this [ __ ] like oh what the [ __ ] is this
like they're hogging like what's this
gay right and then I'm like you want you
have see
or humping on the ground mounting each
other dude like [ __ ] just relax their
nuts are actually rubbing on their body
right oh yeah so I wonder if they're
their payouts gonna go down or if it's
gonna be effective we gonna get fined or
whatever I don't know boys because since
now Showtime is issuing full refunds to
these people that got affected with
these glitches and also like UFC pass
which is what Bart ordered yeah that
failed yeah I'm actually wondering if
Bart's gonna try to get a refund but
yeah there's even this lawsuit that's
been filed against Showtime because of
this whole glitches that sucks cuz yeah
the people were saying like they didn't
see HD you which was a big paid for they
already saw it was just a whole bunch of
errors or like flags or a beeper and
yeah it was for us yeah I was like hey
the boys are it's not matching the mouth
and it was like a Chinese kung fu movie
my fix [ __ ] on my laptop because I
thought I was because I showed up to the
BBQ late so I was like well I can't miss
this fight so I'm just gonna watch it
here I just bought it and so but I mean
you actually came through I actually
feel great cuz I don't waste my money we
almost did though we started panicking
when the fight was coming up to our
friend he pulled it up on his phone on
my good a little stream like a hundred
million illegal streams
oh my bad yeah they're people like
periscoping there and there were like
three hundred thousand people watching a
periscope yeah dude did anybody watch
the undercard [ __ ] yes yeah yeah we did
bit [ __ ] elbow guy yeah yeah I was I
kidding
I remember names either it's funny
because I found it to be like because we
had nobody knows anything about the
fighters obviously so for super nerds I
thought it to be like that was when when
it was like we're all watching a bad
movie together and we're making fun of
it right
and but then when the fight happens
every was like shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah yeah energy was dude we kept
clowning on the corona girls they were
there's like 200 million people watching
or some [ __ ] yeah the girl was like she
pulled up the other girls come over here
and they had the same smile you can tell
their cheeks were hurting because it's
so smiling there's like yeah that was a
four-hour smile they had the same face
for like what six to nine or ten I think
it held like that just did hairspray
that's the rub like [ __ ] on their teeth
so they don't yeah Vaseline baby I hope
vastly on their teeth beauty beauty
pageant thing good to do that in dance
see that you keep smiling because you've
been filming taking me as a whole day
I'm like oh that's like when youtubers
like meet and greets because you're
smiling so much your face starts yeah so
towards the end I was like this yeah I
know like that's David that I'm grumpy
David it's like the words are happy
about my face hurts yeah hey how's it
going sounds about right
yeah hello everybody
if you like the video make sure that you
guys leave us a thumbs up because if not
I'm gonna find you where you live and
I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you with
you all right
other than that you know there's like
more videos up there bro
[Music]